[Music]
hey it's me Mario
and it's of me not Mario dance cyber
yeah drama that cyber channel on YouTube
and twitch nip and PGN squadron
youtube.com slash user slash games
thanks thanks Mario super macho my god I
talk on my [ __ ] not going to where
the trends are reactive super mario to
see game trailer III we know the deal
whoa it's just like the movie like the
food I didn't realize
Marga I'm talking about
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
Oh
what
[Music]
[Music]
Oh kidnap again of course
to remember this is the card yo came to
find something else to do so you can
like disguise yourself as buddy talk any
of you took a selfie Epico kami you
possess them yeah an interesting new
feature for our design for us advance
our mustaches those Pauline Pauline from
Donkey Kong yeah
where wait yeah go back right there
that's like that's her hair that's her
signature dress but now she had happy
like sir Mike happy there snap sexual
atomic with hot in speed and ran that's
a cool feature with the happening I and
remember because you know son but this
is like a tomb with like n64 sunshine
yeah and now this one you know because
there's always much like random Mario
games in between movies and yeah I mean
it was way better than the water thing
he has sunshine I'm a frickin water
backpack the hats
cool I mean it's awesome when they made
this have a signature saying we're now
we can do things like like versus like a
boomerang and a worse is that looks a
collection thing yeah I've one thing
that's always kind of bugged me about
the 3d Mario games is that you have
punching like in Mario 6 before you can
punch but you have to get so close to
home yeah that sometimes you just end up
getting hit and yeah but this is like a
nice way to like fight enemies without
having to be here totally I love the
fact because they really when they could
be switch Nintendo Direct they revealed
a trailer for it I was unsure what was
what it was going like well this is
beyond the Mushroom Kingdom
yeah no I mean audience yeah he's going
going back in time to another world good
night no come on over the place here
well I'm really interested to see
because that the city's new table city
new and it's all Donkey Kong theme
yeah so one are we can see talking on
that's where a Pauline comes yes yes
okay so I'm wondering if it's gonna be
like each level is gonna have like maybe
another Nintendo character gradually
slit in it
Tendo Cinematic Universe it looks like
there's a lot more like structure to the
game that we didn't get from the first
yeah
trailer the first trailer looks like
super open-world you're kinda like how
would I find anything yeah fun as hell
looks really I got saying you're
watching a bunch of III trailers most of
them the big ones that everyone wants to
check out a like heavy and serious and
badass and all that it's not because I'm
like oh lighthearted like it's so
colorful and life is over in the data
from what the Nintendo
conference from what I heard is like
Metroid Prime for which I pumped out of
my mind for yeah the Yoshi game a new
Kirby game Nintendo blood drops so many
cool things and then seeing like a good
chunk of the game I'm super Mario oddity
it's gonna be good honest with ya I
wonder how the production stuff works
what are the benefits are you
camouflaging yourself or you can you do
something when you're it looks like I
mean when you possess the bullets bill
you could fly around wherever you wanted
to go so you could use their powers yeah
so they whatever they you you know I
imagine it's some old mobility sort of
ah anything Wow
Super Mario gets mystical on us and also
because we both went what the whole like
to you ye yeah your old Pharaoh's a
really nice touch to have in this
trailer because I was at 1up bar I'm
sure there's like maybe they don't exist
in like wherever you're from one of bars
that there's some arcade market yeah and
they had the the one of the arcades had
the original Nintendo Mario on there oh
awesome and I just it's like so plain
that today like there's a fun game you
know n64 version is still my favorite of
all time but it's playing the og Mario
the - yeah who's run straight don't run
you can't Rebecca yeah that knows this
is a good old days so yeah this looks
like a game that this is going to be a
total blast it comes out a few days
before Halloween which is perfect this
is one of the scariest games of all time
I mean one last like real quick thing I
love how Mario deals with feeling that
nostalgic part of them yeah for this
it's like yes there's the two bit and
it's like Oh 8-bit Mario bubble bug but
it looks like it could be a real cool
mechanic in there with going into a
mural so obviously you're going to be
using the walls to get around that's oh
yeah well and then you look how sonic
fills that and they just like oh we're
just going to put Classic Sonic in and
you just like classic Sonic level and
it's like okay
now I feel like Mario is in and
someone's not entirely but in like the
way how like what James Bond is for
movies is kind of like
Mario is for video games I just keep
Mario go and keep them evolving but just
keep Mario yeah I mean you can't lose
Mario he's like the start of the game
yeah
the game looks great it looks like
they're once again innovate like that's
why the battement and knows each game
innovates in such a unique way this time
with throwing your cap without is really
cool yeah I wait for you seeing the
footage I'm a preferred copy over the
water man the walk back one percent and
I know that they showed in the previous
trailer you can also jump up the cap
yeah so you can use it as a platform and
that's super cool so you can shrink into
the cat Jimmy go inside the can it's a
cattle hole does it have each or is it
four key will never never know welcome
so we bought it hey subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell that cyber channel on twitch TV
that cyber channel on youtube.com he's
also part of the TGM squadron on
youtube.com slash user slash games live
streams recorded video person I do have
a different gaming gaming dan dan thank
you so much for being here this is the
last trailer we watched I don't know the
last one I uploaded with him behind the
scenes going to leave now le now ok
great [ __ ] off like an hour drive out